hi let's talk about object-oriented
programming in Python first
object-oriented programming is a
programming paradigm it's a lot like
it's in the same category as things like
functional programming and imperative
programming but object-oriented
programming is going to be the
programming paradigm that describes most
of the code that you're going to
interact with in 601 so it's important
to understand how it works and how in
particular you want to be able to code
in an object-oriented programming
paradigm in Python so today I'm gonna go
over a quick crash course on
object-oriented programming and also
indicate all the little tips and tricks
you need in order to program in Python
let's look at what I have written up so
the most important thing to remember
when you're learning about the
oppertunity programming paradigm is that
everything is an object and what I mean
when I say that more people mean when
people say that is that the the ideals
behind the paradigm is are that you
interact with your code in the same way
that you would interact with objects in
the physical world right there's a
particular piece of paper on the desk in
front of me and it is a kind of piece of
paper so I know how to interact with it
the way that you would interact with any
other piece of paper if you want to
codify this in an object or a
programming paradigm you write up
classes classes are your basic unit of
code block they describe what a what a
thing can do
and what a thing has or what what
attributes a thing has and in
object-oriented programming frequently
object-oriented programming in Python we
refer to those things as methods or
functions that a particular object may
have and attributes or a particular
variables that object may have once
you've codified what a particular of
what any object of a particular class
can do you can then use the code that
you've written to instantiate an object
an object is the functional unit in the
object-oriented programming paradigm
it's the thing that you interact with
and tell what to do and you know produce
the results for you it's it's the thing
that makes up the you know in in classes
are sort of the two things that you need
to think about but you also have to
think about how they're different I have
a particular seed of paper in front of
me it has all the properties of a sheet
paper and when I think about all the
things I can do to a sheet of paper that
constitutes a class but the particular
piece of paper that I have is an
instance of that class it's a it's a
particular piece of paper that's that's
the gist of object-oriented programming
and the things that you need to know now
that I've covered them I'm gonna go over
the most basic class I could come up
with in terms of object-oriented
programming in Python this is a class
that specifies what a 601 staff member
has in terms of an attribute or a method
in Python if I want every if I want
every instance of a particular class or
every staff member of the class staff
member 601 to have a particular
attribute I can specify like this every
instance of staff 601 is going to have
an attribute room and that attribute
room is going to be set to the string
describing 34 501 the 601 lab if I want
every 601 staff member to be able to do
a particular thing or have a particular
method or call a particular function
then I specify it like this this is the
beginning of a method in the class
staff601 it's called say hi I'll talk
about self in a second don't worry about
it act as though you know it if this is
your introduction to Python programming
then you know pretty much pretend it's
not there it's kind of like this we'll
cover that in a second
and if any instance of the staff601
class calls say hi then hello will be
printed to standard out I have a couple
examples up on the board behind me and
if you type them into idle and see what
their return is like you'll be able to
or you know after you've typed in this
you'll be able to interact a little bit
better with what Python considers
classes and objects and that sort of
thing
so if you look at type staff601 it'll
tell you about a class which is an
object in itself but it's a
specification for instances of an object
if you want to instantiate an object
that is of type staff601 you need to use
the parens on
and this treats staff601 like a call and
creates an object if you just type
staff601 you're just reassigning the
staff six in one class to the name keep
you and that's not useful every every
staff601 member should not be considered
a kendra right
once you have instantiate 'add a
particular object of type staff601 you
can look at the type of that object
right now you've got one object keep you
myself and that is a class of staff601
likewise now that you have this object
to keep you you can look at it after
buttes and methods if you look at KP u
dot room then it should print to the
screen 34 or 501
that's because that's you know the
attribute associated with this instance
if you call KP u dot say hi it will use
the method in the class type of this
object so when you call dot say hi
it looks at cape you looks at the type
says that's a type staff601 goes to
class staff601 finds the definition for
say hi' and then execute this code
hopefully that all made sense now i want
to talk about itself and you might say
kendra i don't understand where that
comes into play and you didn't even use
it over here if you're familiar with c++
or java self is a lot like this self is
an implicit argument passed in here even
though you specified 0 arguments it's
considered the first argument and you'll
probably see a lot of type errors when
you're first programming in
object-oriented programming that say
that you've either passed in too many or
too few arguments it has to do with this
definition with self self says I am
talking about myself that's not
particularly intuitive but I'll try to
explain a little bit more when K Pugh
calls dot say hi say hi always has an
implicit reference to whatever called it
when you look at this code other
instances can call this code right if I
had an instance
of adam' parts or an instance of actual
they would also have access to the
method say hi and when they called say
hi say hi would point back to the class
definition but also have a reference to
whatever instance called it so when you
substitute in this self you substitute
in whatever instance called the method
that doesn't seem particularly useful
right now because that class definition
does not actually make any use of the
self or the ability to use unique
instances of an object as sort of unique
storage containers right I'm kpu I'm
different from Adam hearts and therefore
I should be able to have different
attributes or different methods or
things that absolutely differently from
the way they do for Adam I'm gonna look
at a revised definition of class
staff601 and that that definition will
use self in a way that indicates that
you can have different functionality for
different instances it's right here
class def 601 it looks really similar in
fact the first few lines are exactly the
same we've got a class attribute that
means that every instance of this class
is going to have this attribute because
it's a class attribute if I want
different instantiations of my class to
have different properties then I need to
explicitly address the initialization of
those properties in Python when we want
to do that we define the method in it
and it is a very special method it's got
these underscores it's sort of a I think
it's a protected keyword and it always
has the format self and then whatever
arguments you want to pass in when
you're instantiating an object and it is
not exactly a constructor but for those
of you that are familiar with C++ and
Java it acts like a constructor
immediately after
the object is constructed in it is
called and all this setup that is
required to set up the object happens so
anytime you instantiate an object all of
these things are gonna be executed or
all the things under init is going to be
executed in particular we're going to
set the attribute greeting to whatever
argument we passed in when we
instantiated the object so every every
instance that we create of this class is
going to have the class attribute room
they're all going to be in the same room
but they're also going to have a
greeting and you have the option of
specifying the greeting to be whatever
you want we're gonna make use of this in
the method say hi which still only takes
the argument self or the reference to
whatever object called the method in the
first place that reference is going to
get substituted in here so no matter
which object calls the method you will
have access to its particular greeting
using this syntax let's walk through an
example let's say I make an example of
Adam Hertz and he is a staff601 member
and his greeting is going to be hi
likewise let's make another instance of
me using the new staff601 definition
make sure you type this in because it's
not gonna work otherwise and make my
greeting hello as opposed to just hi if
you call the say hi method using hearts
then you should get a different result
then when you call the say hi method
using kpu but if you call the room
method or if you excuse me if you were
after the room attribute of both
instances then you should get the same
result because this is the class
attribute definition whereas this is
this attribute is specific to each
instance
that's all I have to say for now about
object-oriented programming
in my next video I'll start to talk
about inheritance which is another
really important property in 601 and
also object-oriented Python and also has
some slip-ups so I'd like to talk to you
about those that next